ladies and gentlemen to present the  award in this next category there is one  of Hollywood's most distinguished  citizens miss Irene Dunne the  nominations for the best achievement in  directing are Fred cinnamon for the  Columbia picture From Here to Eternity  Charles Walters from Metro Goldwyn Mayer  Lily William Wyler for Roman Holiday  Paramount George Stevens for Shayne  paramount and Billy Wilder for Paramount  Stalag 17 the winner is  Fred cinnamon far from here  great writer thank you I would like to  thank the Pacific Command at the United  States Army all the way from general or  Daniel down to warrant officer bill  Mullen for the wonderful help to gave us  his picture in addition I would like to  thank mr. Harry Cohn and all my friends  at Columbia studio especially Dan  taradash and Buddy Adler for wonderful  Association thank you very much  Thank You mr. cinnamon mr. Don